changement de cap à la cité des sciences
et de l'industrie de la villette trois
mois après sa nomination le nouveau
président christian barback entend
rééquilibrer une gestion contestée
dorénavant la présence financière des
entreprises sera plus importante dans
les projets d'expo notamment c'est une
affaire de santé budgétaire le point
avec jules césar mur ascione et
dominique duchateau
on l'avait peut-être oublié la villette
c'est la cité des sciences et de
l'industrie
il est vrai que jusqu'à ce jour 90 % des
expositions et des consacrés aux
sciences contre 10% seulement à
l'industrie sens inversé pour autant la
tendance de l'année 88 est au
rééquilibrage avec un ensemble de
manifestations assurant une meilleure
représentation des mécanismes de
l'entreprise et de ses métiers pour y
parvenir
matériellement d'abord la direction de
l'établissement compte sur le parrainage
par des entreprises de certaines de ses
activités
je crois qu'il est normal que nous
louions un certain nombre d' espaces à
des entreprises qui veulent faire passer
des messages mais toujours pour faire
apparaître leurs plus technologique leur
plus scientifique
je crois que nous pouvons rendre
montants présentés la science c'est à
dire ses explications
l'industrie c'est à dire les mécanismes
qui permettent de passer de la science à
ces résultats
et puis la culture parce que tout n'est
pas si tout débat scientifique tout
débat industriel doit s'inscrire dans
l'avenir de notre pays dans l'avenir de
notre civilisation depuis plus d'un an
la fondation vilain d'entreprise
regroupe 35 grandes sociétés françaises
une fondation qui représente un apport
de 85 millions de francs sous la forme
de prêts ou don en matériel et
prestations diverses à la cité la
villette ne sera pas transformé en
vitrine géante pour entrepreneurs
leur présence est souhaitée pour des
raisons budgétaires mais aussi créatrice
expositions et de public encore plus
vaste culturel et scientifique la cité
de la villette est également une
entreprise à la recherche de l'équilibré
ce